you know how much fun they could have
like the trans issue they can't touch it
they can't touch it so I want to show
you this clip of of Joe Rogan now Rogan
for my opinion has not been good on
Israel he has for a long time just put
on like radical crazy leftist whatever I
sense he may be going through a bit of
an Awakening on this thing because he's
seeing the craziness right I'd be happy
to go on his show and explain the the
history of this uh if he wants me that
that would be fine but he could put on
anyone to do it doesn't have to be me
but he's been pretty bad on Israel over
the years um and and put on some of the
just really the worst people related to
all of this he had Coleman Hughes on
Coleman Hughes uh is a guy I've had him
on the show he happens to be black he's
an interesting thinker uh and Coleman
was laying out a pretty clear
explanation of there are kind of good
guys and bad guys here and the media has
been lying about the hospitals and
everything else and Rogan brought
brought up how the left because they own
culture they've they've owned comedy
forever but even that is changing he's
talking about the onion and the Babylon
be specifically take a look New York
Times patiently awaiting Zoom call from
Hamas to see what they should print to
today yeah so this is this is about the
hospital yeah that is the Babylon B
thank God they exist like they they
disprove the idea that it's only
leftwing people that are funny yeah that
is not true The Babylon B is they out
onion the onion often they're amazing
better than the onion used to be great
still is good they still knocking out of
the park every now and again but you
know they're young Progressive Lial
constrained by a certain ideology that
doesn't allow them to poke fun at
certain things you know how much fun
they could have like the trans issue
they can't touch it they can't touch it
yeah Rachel l v they can't touch it
leave it alone get out of there it's too
hot I'll clean that up for you I mean
the the onion is abject horrible it's
woke trash and nothing that is woke is
funny the the uh headline that they were
reading can we put it up there it
illustrates everything we were talking
about before New York Times patiently
awaiting Zoom call from h
to see what they should print today and
as you know when that hospital uh
bombing the Islamic Jihad bomb that blew
up and destroyed the parking lot next to
the hospital not 500 people and all that
New York Times three times changed their
headline also on the front page of the
New York Times they showed a building
that wasn't even the hospital underneath
the headline that was talking about the
hospital